hey guys what's up this is andrew for
10senses.com
so
i'm going to make a big update guys on
what is happening right now with gme amc
as well but emc is a bit weak
and the rest of the market so let's get
into it
all right guys so we had some big big
big moves
in the past two days um sorry i wasn't
uh here so i couldn't make updates but
let's have a look at that let's see what
are the resistances level let's see if
we have some room to push higher
um and let's see what can happen so i'm
going to start with gme guys because
this is where we have action this is
where the volume is
so basically two days ago
so no sorry so yesterday here
we had some um big move
happening plus 30 percent when gme
announced the release of its own crypto
so this is bullish of course i mean this
is a good reason to to
create you know fomo and for investors
to jump in gme definitely but guys
let's have a look at the crypto market
it's not good looking good and we're
gonna have a look at um
at the global market as well that maybe
maybe he's gonna get out of trouble soon
so if this happens the crypto probably
gonna rally uh equity is gonna rally and
gme has a lot of potential so
uh i'm gonna analyze that very soon but
first let's focus on gamestop so what do
we have here in my last video i was
telling you guys that we're having you
know this areas of consolidation
here
here here
and
here we had a breakout breakout with
volume all right so this is a nice
consolidation on very low volume those
who followed the course
that is still available
um in the description of the video you
guys know that this is exactly what we
are looking for so here
uh we closed at the top of the day which
is very bullish
and so the next day we had a follow-up
through
in the same direction so
let's discuss quickly the resistance
areas first
so
to find the resistance areas guys as
usual
bam bam bam
let me get rid of that tag tag
okay
we look at previous considerations at
previous
areas of resistance or support it can
work in both ways so here i'm already
having that but let me maybe adjust now
that's good guys look here feb 22 this
was resistance
march 22 this was support here
april 20 april may 22 it was resistance
so now it is resistance and as you can
see we went through it
with volume increasing volume guys this
is reminding me something right so let's
see if we're able to be in this
situation are we here and are we gonna
have a massive massive move coming uh
here or not let's see
um
[Music]
so for now
the volume is increasing
and we have another green candle we
didn't close at the top this time but
it's fine
we have some profit taking so let's
discuss resistances so as i said here is
one so 130 the usual 130.
the next one is 140 and 152
all right 152 why because you have the
resistance here very clearly it was a
consolidation with a clear resistance in
the recent past so this has a lot of
weight and we have the 200-day moving
average coming in right so we have a
double resistance so this whole area i
guess is an area of resistance all right
so
uh we can very well go through it but we
just need bias to keep you know being
strong so we need the volume to stay
uh this is important we have earnings
coming
all right just here
first of june guys so it's gonna be in
two trading days right that that uh
yeah three trading days even
yeah three training days so um
[Music]
let's see what we're gonna have here
but
what can i say here what can i say guys
um
i would
say that
we had a lot of buyers true the question
is
are they gonna keep buying and are we
gonna have sellers all right and for now
i'm think that sellers are here but
buyers are just stronger
for this move to continue we need
sellers to
stop doing what they do
and they're going to be you know even
more buyers
compared to the total number of
investors and for that to happen
we need to have a strong bullish signal
on the global markets i'm going to come
to that let me first look at amc guys
once again lagging
it's not the first time we see that we
saw that in the way on the way down we
saw that on the way up before
um
you know jme is much stronger again than
amc amc did some nice move but very
small compared to jimmy but in the same
time at the same time there was no good
news about emc
the situation is still the same in the
last video i was telling you guys that
you know we have here
this
trendlines that we can do and as you can
see they're acting still here as
resistance
it's not perfect the 20-day moving
average is coming here it is the one
actually that really rejected the price
action at 12.8
um
today
and
uh
i mean yesterday when you're gonna watch
this video
but
uh but it's still good we still have
some bullish moves with increasing
volume so here i would say
that if we have this breakout here above
basically the 30 level it's going to be
a very very nice buying opportunity i'm
going to personally increase my position
if we are able to reach this level
uh especially if i have actually some
good signals from the global markets i'm
not gonna spend too much time on amc
here because guys for now we're still in
the same pattern all right we didn't
break out from this bearish trend we're
still bearish in the medium term but we
are bullish on the short term as you can
see with the increasing volume on the
way up uh we are below the 20 day moving
average guys that's not good we need to
take it back first and then we need to
have some horizontal breakouts so 13.3
this is the reason why
here if the volume keeps going up uh
we're gonna look good so we need to wait
for close above 13.3
uh bam bam bam
now global market guys
what is happening here
uh
so this is what i've been saying in my
discord for the past two three days guys
we are still playing this this uh very
strand
okay so my scenario was one two three
four
and maybe a fifth wave to 240 all right
so very bearish but it's possible i give
it a 45 probability so roughly 50 50.
the alternative scenario is that we have
completed
a one two three four five already
it's possible as well
sorry
bam
and that's right now we are gonna start
uh this scenario a bullish move so the
reason why i give a slightly higher
probability to the
bullish case is because of the low
volume that we had here on the way down
as you can see look at that day
i've mentioned that already but let's
look at it again
uh 18 may 18th so this was nine days ago
you can see the volume a strong move
down minus five percent with a low
volume compared to the big ones we had
before and the whole period
is a very low volume period which is a
consolidation which very often happens
before reversals so
uh i want to believe that a reversal is
coming but for now we are bearish we are
below the 20 day moving average just
like amc
we are below this trend line
and to me we are missing maybe one wave
all right so i give
also a probability that is not you know
uh negligible 45 to a scenario where we
drop lower i hope we won't but i
personally sold this right i posted the
alert in my discord uh yesterday i
bought some sq2 which is the same
because once again i'm playing this move
guys because
i'm having
a long position on many stocks
i took some profits on my short position
so now i can
around here
almost close to the lows uh at
i can show you that on s triple q i took
a profit at 59
so
roughly here right
okay
so
it was a good trade and so this is the
reason why i'm happy to reload i bought
yesterday at 52.25
and i announced in my discord of course
i have a stop loss at 49
point
75 i'm gonna keep this trade only put
500 us dollars because it's you know a
very nice protection for not a big loss
500 us dollars for whole portfolio
protection it's
very very uh cheap
uh so i'm happy to you know take this
protection again
uh and i
hope i'm gonna lose my money on this one
because i really hope we're gonna have a
bull run coming yes because this is so
much fun uh for those who are with me in
discord some of you complain that i'm
not posting a lot of alerts i'm sorry
about that but i do it because i don't
want you guys to get burned
all right and i know that during this
very volatile
market um conditions
technical analysis is full of tricks
guys so that's why i only trade big uh
etfs like sqqq triple q
i keep my positions on my stocks i don't
want to stop dispositions
but
i play
moves on once again those big volume etf
that give me good results with technical
analysis so that's why guys i'm very
calm in my discord but don't worry
i'm having my watch list
full of
ideas just here as you can see
i'm monitoring all of the stocks guys
all right so you have around 200 stocks
that i'm keeping an eye on all right all
of that i have levels and
i'm ready to give you the go whenever
things will happen to me once again i'm
looking for perfect kind of situations
which is not happening often
and uh let's be honest i had a lot of
false signals on stocks on bullish
signals on the way down so that's why i
i don't want to give you too much too
many alerts and i want to focus on
protection because this is what i think
is important in this kind of situations
um so to conclude here triple q guys we
are not out of trouble like i said i
took a short position here because i
believe there is still a high
probability
uh that we go to very low levels here
um
we can see we can have a look at uh dx y
guys
much better
uh
back to i would say a more acceptable
territory 101 above 100 or three it's
not looking good and the us 10 year
yield same
giving us some relief at 275 guys so
those two indicators are back so that's
good we have lower volume on the way
down on triple q
uh
so
i hope we're gonna break out here if we
do i'm just gonna
cut all my short position at once or
maybe twice here all right probably some
here and some on the retest and then
here i'm gonna reload on stocks
hopefully this is what is awaiting us
it would be so cool to have some you
know strong bull market during the
summer everyone would feel happy some
squeezes happening guys so let's hope
for that but
let's be prepared for the worst
uh and cheer for for the best right
so that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys